here's to good friends cheers Cheers
hmm a sort of an oaky afterbirth mm-hmm
what was that that really really showed
him up witness I brought in some
burritos or some colored greens or some
pad thai love pad thai
it's collard greens what it's collard
greens Klan doesn't really make sense
because you don't call them collared
people that's offensive hey Pam all this
stuff with Kevin um pretty scary but I'm
thinking that next time you're in the
shower you should check yourself out you
know give yourself an exam those things
are like ticking time bags all right
think about it
something to think about there is
there's a traitor traitor traitor come
here you come here yeah the product your
prank at all but my son returns
Webster's dictionary defines wedding as
the fusing of two metals with a hot
torch well you know something I think
you guys are two metals gold medals live
and let live
what live and let live I'm not familiar
with that explosion James Bond it
doesn't make any sense
of course I'm alive two queens on casino
night I am going to drop a deuce on
everybody Pam would you stand up for a
sec
hmm see how relaxed I am I like this
chair
offers good support it is economically
correct it's a good chair I just want to
say for the record I did not kill anyone
Stanley was attacked by his own heart
and he should be released from the
hospital and back in the office in a
couple days did you shout fire causing a
panic yes I shouted fire I shouted many
things I also shouted instructions on
how to get out of the building so you
can imagine my frustration as safety
officer when nobody would heed of what
he did he had no one headed take headed
no one would take headed of my
instructions should you think I don't
see my coworker heat up heating this
right now would you like to try next
absolutely I would not you know who I
really think should go Stanley it's not
a good idea Michael he needs to rest no
rest for the sick several times a day
Michael says words that are way beyond
my vocab this is going do you okay
remember spider face no okay because the
quote was cut off your nose to spite her
face okay yep Michael it's really good
to see you hey why are you wearing a
turtleneck alright Michael I feel I was
a little harsh yesterday I am I spent
the afternoon in the park trying to feed
the pigeons I guess they all flew West
for the winter the old Michael Scott
might have taken this but not the new
Michael Scott they are in for a bitter
surprise I am not to be trifled with
do not let your imagination run amuck
run what amok it means don't let your
imagination run out of control why
didn't you just say that Pam Michael
do not let your imagination run out of
control that's easy for you to say you
have a bad imagination it's stupid I
live in a fantasy world have us got a
minute yes Andy
I freaked out why did do I'd say he was
late this morning
he didn't say that's weird because I was
walking past his desk and I saw this
which is a tollbooth receipt from New
York City
stamped really early this morning why
would white go to New York without
telling anyone you think he went to see
Jan that's not like him is it someone
told me a story about this with like
laundry and betrayal did you betray
Dwight and try to steal this job or
something no you are remembering it
wrong
Dwight betrayed me once before so this
is his strike too
you know what they say fool me once
strike one
but fool me twice strike three
five four three there is no way I will
resign it wouldn't be fair not to the
good workers I work with not to my
clients and especially not to me let's
not forget who this whole resigning
business is about anyway if I could
leave you with one thought remember it
wasn't me they're trying to make me an
escape code if I am fired I swear to God
that every single piece of copier paper
in this town is going to have the f-word
on it you leaked it I don't know what to
do do I go tell Joe or I don't want
everyone to keep blaming the wrong
person I don't know what the best plan
is damn Oh God
my mind is going a mile an hour that
fast
oh okay you know what let's just go to
the dump
start looking Ryan come on Chuck got in
my car
Michael why would we all go to the dump
why because I am NOT going to call Sabre
and say hi you know is very valuable
expensive leads that you gave us earlier
today well because it would screw up by
a staff member there now in the city
dump not just staff Michael
you well that's not the way it's gonna
sound here's what we'll do we'll go to
the dump
we'll look around then we'll all go out
get pizza maybe catch movie late night
drink some more pizza call it a night
what do you eat doesn't have to mean
pizza I go for a falafel
really I'm not going you did this not us
okay no you encouraged it you were
complicit complicit you were all
successor EES Michael oh you're still
here I have your back yet oh you've been
very good this year
oh yeah except for cheating on your wife
daughters is in the Bible what do you
get God scented candles
oh well that's appropriate a lot of fire
we're going better get used to it you're
going to a GLL double hockey sticks
David guess who I am sitting here
dressed as I'm not going to guess you
could tell me I will give you a hint his
last name was Christ he's a power flight
he can heal leopards oh contraption
she's contracted everybody knows it was
Andy and it is not fair for us all to
take the fall for his big stupid mouth
ridiculous Angela and like I'm gonna
believe one of his sperm lovers okay
okay you know what this is disgusting
this is like a witch hunt this is like
the Blair Witch hunt project there are
many different schools of thought on
capital punishment that was awesome what
should we ask hey can i play why don't
you ask if daryl is bad friend who
backstabs people in the back we have one
question to ask the spirit world and you
wants to ask that he says no well well
well how the turntables Jim Halpert is
smudge and arrogant think you mean smug
arrogance tonight the Scranton Business
Park is having casino night and we are
converting our warehouse into a
full-blown gambling hall and I know it's
illegal in Pennsylvania but it's for
charity and I consider myself a great
philanderer why I'm taking
responsibility and it is up to me to get
rid of the curse that hit Meredith with
my car I'm not superstitious but I'm I
am a little stitches tell him to call me
ASAP as possible
Thanks look it's really simple we just
want you guys to treat us with respect
see that's we're talking about did you
hear that Twite yes did you hear that
Michael no Dwight respect RESP sweetie
find out what it means to me Jim I am
downloading some n3p
music yet for a CD mixtape close Holly
Oh any man who says he totally
understands women is a fool because they
are understandable Kelly has an eating
disorder yeah she always eats my lunch
anorexia she's no she's an anorexic we
should do something nothing could be
done just tell everybody best I guess
you